Speaker 1: Fox News host Tucker Carlson was off
last week. I'm sure many of you were absolutely
devastated by this. There was even a conspiracy
theory floating around that the FBI waited to
raid Donald Trump's home in Florida until Tucker
Carlson was off the airwaves so that he wouldn't
be in studio to give a fiery response to it
all. Well, one of the guest hosts last week
for Tucker was Brian KILMEADE, who oops, aired
a doctored photo of the judge who signed off
on the search warrant of Donald Trump depicting
him hanging out with Ghislaine Maxwell. But the
host on last Friday's show is the one I want
to talk about here today. And that was none
other than Tulsi Gabbard, which may come as a
shock to you. All right. Because Tulsi Gabbard,
I thought she was a liberal. She ran for president
in 2020. On the Democratic side, she was called
even more progressive and more principled
than Bernie Sanders, of all people. Well,
it's not clear that she ever was those things
or ever held strong ideological beliefs at all,
or she was always grifting or as some allege, that
she's working for a foreign country. That's what
Hillary Clinton said. She's been inching tulsi
that is more and more to the right over time
going on fox news voting present on donald trump's
impeachment vote to heal the country. And she also
spoke at CPAC last year. And now the grift is
complete because she has filled in for Tucker
Carlson on his show, Tucker Carlson tonight. And
what did she do during the show? Did she talk
about universal health care or did she talk about
criminal justice reform or any of these other
issues that a true progressive would want to share
with a Fox News audience? No. She instead decided
to run interference for Donald Trump. Let's watch
some of Tulsa's monologue and pick it apart and
see if there's anything progressive here at all
in this commentary or if it's like anything else
that you could find for a Fox News personality.
Speaker 6: Now, whatever your views are on Donald
Trump, there's no denying that the unprecedented
raid on his Palm Beach home earlier this week has
set our country on a dangerous new course, and
there's no turning back. The FBI's raid on Mar
a Lago changed the country that we grew up, and we
grew up believing that, hey, our government will
apply the law. Equally to all Americans, whether
you're Republican or a Democrat, we're seeing more
and more that that country no longer exists.
Speaker 1: Okay. So we're only 26 seconds into
the monologue, and I already have to cut it short
and step in here because there's already a lot to
break down. So Tulsi says that the raid on Mar
a Lago was unprecedented, which yes, it was,
but also what Donald Trump did as president and
what he's accused of doing in a criminal context.
That's also unprecedented. So as David likes to
say, when you have unique inputs, you're going to
have unique outputs. Just by saying that what the
FBI and DOJ did was unprecedented, that doesn't
mean that it was necessarily wrong or unjustified.
Tulsi then talks about how the FBI raid has set us
on a dangerous course from which we cannot turn
back. Again, it was Donald Trump who set us on
this course. The FBI was merely responding to the
actions that the former president allegedly did,
as is their job as a law enforcement agency.
That is, after all, what they do. And then Tulsi
appeals to the elderly Fox News demographic
by giving this rainbows and rose petals and
gumdrop depiction of the America we once knew, the
America that we knew growing up, saying that that
America is long gone because now the law is no
longer being applied equally. And this is done
for a couple of reasons. Like, for one, it never
really was this way. We never really had this
glossy depiction of America and having a perfect
criminal justice system. We've always had a two
tiered justice system, especially as it breaks
down on racial and class lines. But then also what
the FBI and the DOJ are doing investigating Donald
Trump because they believe he committed crimes.
That is applying the law equally. Applying the
law unequally would be saying like, okay, well,
we think he's guilty. We think that he did illegal
stuff here. But he's a former president, after
all. He's a billionaire. He's a powerful person.
So we're going to let him get away with it. We're
just going to look the other way. So that would be
unjustified. That would be a backwards depiction
of the country. So it's taken me, what, 2 minutes
here to break down the nonsense that Tulsi was
able to spew in 26 seconds. Let's keep playing
the clip and see if it gets any better at all.
Speaker 6: Law enforcement, the highest levels of
government, whether it's the DOJ, the Department
of Homeland Security, the FBI and now even the
IRS have been weaponized to target the political
opponents of the Union Party, the permanent
Washington and the Biden regime. Attorney General
Merrick Garland has already issued a stark warning
to anyone who dares to disagree with these tactics
that are all hallmarks of a dictatorship.
Speaker 7: Let me address recent unfounded
attacks on the professionalism of the FBI and
Justice Department agents and prosecutors.
I will not stand by silently when
their integrity is unfairly attacked.
Speaker 6: So you are not allowed to disagree
with the FBI. That is the new message.
Speaker 1: All right. So we again, have to stop
it here and jump in. So Telsey first brings up
the story about Biden hiring a bunch of new IRS
agents by way of the Inflation Reduction Act as
a way to raise funds for government programs and
to make sure that people making over $400,000 a
year aren't cheating too much on their taxes. She
tries to tie that in with the FBI's investigation
of Donald Trump. Objection. Relevance. How are
these two things related in the slightest? They're
not. And then Tulsi plays a clip of Merrick
Garland refuting the idea that the DOJ isn't
just following the law and that there are some
political motivations behind what they're doing.
And Tulsi twists that into saying you're not
allowed to disagree with the FBI as if your free
speech rights are being curtailed. That's even
what they had at the lower third graphic. You're
not allowed to disagree with the FBI. Completely
absurd and definitely a manipulation of the video
that she played. So there's Tulsi Gabbard for you,
filling in for Tucker Carlson, definitely taking a
page or two out of his propaganda playbook. It's
long been speculated that Tulsi is vying for a
job at Fox News. And after seeing that, what was
clearly an audition, it does feel like that's the
career path that her career is heading in. When
she left Congress at the beginning of last year,
there was speculation as to what was next
for Tulsi. I always thought it was a Fox
News gig and I'm surprised it hasn't happened
yet. Maybe they just want to have her train a
little bit more with these guest appearances.
Maybe they're trying to find the right dollar
amount for her salary. Maybe they're trying to
figure out what the best time slot is for her.
But I wouldn't be surprised at all if in the next
six months Tulsi has her own show on Fox News.
We're going to go to a break. We'll be back with
more of the David Pakman show right after this.